[Musique]
mais
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la ville de perm située
à 1400 km à l'est de moscou au pied de
montagnes de l'oural cette chaîne
montagneuse forme une frontière
naturelle entre l'europe et l'asie
dès la fondation de la vivre l'industrie
il prend une place importante à l'époque
de la seconde guerre mondiale c'est ici
qu'ont été évacués un grand nombre
d'entreprises de production du pays
aujourd'hui c'est un important centre
industriel scientifique et culturel de
l'oural
votre invité d'aujourd'hui habite dans
l'oural depuis presque 10 ans il
s'appelle xavier fort il est pilote de
montgolfière et producteur de fromage
allant faire sa connaissance
bonjour xavier bonjour y annoncera t
shirt à koné sans pareil de même alors
belleville un superbe bah oui on a de la
chance
alors un conte - pourquoi l'oural
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de qu'est ce qui t'a
attiré dans l'oural alors moi j'avais
déjà une amie
qui représentant de la ville de perm à
bruxelles elle savait que moi je faisais
de la montgolfière gg leur nez en ballon
quand j'étais en france
et après elle savait qu'il y avait aussi
le festival on dirait à dire
internationale à kumbo et donc suite à
l'invitation je suis venu et j'ai
participé au festival sur une
montgolfière du club de hambourg
et j'avais déjà un intérêt pour la
russie où ça et c'est venu comme ça
après non moi j'ai fait une ruche
première langue je suis déjà venu en 91
ans 93 fois j'avais déjà juin en fait
j'avais eu des velléités de revenir
après l'école quand on est et on avait
fait les échanges avec les événements
ça a été compliqué moi j'avais pu
personnes venues à pernes enfin dans
l'oural parce que j'avais pas réussi à
renouer les contacts que j'avais dans
les autres villes avec mes anciens
correspondants chez dans la région c'est
ça ouais ouais là où j'ai ma maison
c'est un petit village et puis aussi
comme jeu
gd je travaille avec des sociétés je
vais souvent en déplacement dans
d'autres régions j'ai été pendant deux
ans pratiquement sur la région de moscou
quoi
nous avons décidé avec xavier d'aller
chez lui dans le petit village de molex
à 140 km de la grande ville de perm
et en fait la route s'arrête ici donc
déjà la personne qui vient nous endetter
l'espace à 5 c'est par un lieu de
passage c'est une maison que tu as
acheté c'est ça alors oui j'ai acheté
exemple j'ai acheté cet hiver bah on
peut encore jouer à dix ans que par
rapport aux autres maisons qui autour
elle est dans un état habitable
où
c'est une maison au fuste on dit en
france
donc c'est la maison traditionnelle
russe
blige lease back donc et avec une
extension qui a été rajouté en
bois aussi mais pas du même style quoi
c'était moins cher mais c'était dur
comme ça et ça met du coup ça me fait
trop pièce bon il ya il ya un rez de
chaussée il qui donne sur la carte on
peut transformer avec 11 ans une serre
insee recoller à la maison tu vas voir
un jardin ici qu'est ce que les autres
projets donc tu parlais d'une serre
c'est sa balle assez restreinte nantes à
la maison il y aura une autre ère après
pour
me sers que je vais faire des vins que
je faire de façon à ce que je sache elle
me donne des légumes aussi des légumes
d'hiver où ils font au canada
celle là elle sera semi enterrés celle
qui a collé à la maison et l'autre et
sera sera reçu puis
je voir avec le jardin comment ça va
s'organiser si pour commencer à faire du
maraîchage
peut-être pour moi et puis peut-être
s'il ya moyen de vendre des produits
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
et moi ça a été dur de trouver du
travail ici ou ici c'était compliqué au
début parce que
j'ai en fait au départ je n'ai pas le
droit de travailler donc été servi avec
un bees je suis né avec un visa business
donc scellé tu dois t'adapter tu dois
avoir des sous pour mais bon je faisais
du bricolage ce qui est bien en russie
c'est à toujours moyen de trouver si tu
veux travailler tu peux trouver des
petits boulots t'as pas eu des moments
d'hésitation tu t'es dit mais qu'est ce
que je fais ici pourquoi je rentre pas
en france
[Musique]
peut-être une fois
j'étais gay j'en avais marre ouais mais
je me disais si je rentre en france je
vais faire quoi maintenant parce que
j'étais parti depuis tellement longtemps
que que ça change pourquoi j'étais parti
justement que c'était compliqué pour moi
de vivre en france trouver du travail
que même à quatre diplômes je vais pas
bosser donc je me suis dit si je rentre
en france je veux faire quoi donc tu
t'es dit finalement peut-être qu'en vo
si j'ai plus de chance ça bah il
faudrait c'est est ce que je me suis je
m'étais dit déjà en début ou en revenant
que sûrement possibilité de faire
quelque chose en russie et ce qui est
arrivé avec les
et des sanctions ça a été un petit peu
un petit coup de pouce ce qu'on a
commencé à me poser des questions mais
faire du fromage moi j'étais venu pour
faire de l'agriculture on va dire
biologique ou et puis maintenant ça va
plus je me suis plus axé sur
l'agroécologie
donc voilà c'est ce qui me fait rester
c'est que de toute façon
ici je me suis habitué et que ici les
gens ils sont beaucoup plus sympa tous
tes projets se sont plutôt ici c'est ça
il ya l'idée de monter une petite ferme
de faire plusieurs ateliers de
transformation de vente de produits
français et puis ben nous on fera des
fromages toi ce sera le fromager bah moi
je serais plus j'ai plus envie de faire
un fromage en fera un petit peu mais
j'ai plus en moi je suis bien et d'or je
m'occuperai plus des vaches du foin de
et côté technique ouais c'est plus mon
truc
la vie fort est née en 1975 à reims dans
le nord-est de la france son père est
directeur d'un organisme de formation
continue
après le lycée où il étudie le russe en
première langue xavier s'oriente vers
l'enseignement technique et obtient un
brevet de technicien en électrochimie
quelques temps après avoir commencé à
travailler dans sa spécialité une
proposition de travail près de reims en
tant qu'équipier de montgolfières le
séduit après plusieurs années il devient
pilote professionnel de ballons et
accumulent les heures de vol intéressé
depuis longtemps par l'agriculture
biologique il effectue en parallèle une
formation dans ce domaine dans le but de
créer son entreprise
mais ces projets ne se concrétise pas
par l'intermédiaire d'une amie russe il
est invité dans l'avis de concours pour
participer au festival de montgolfières
qui s'y tient tous les ans accueilli
chaleureusement et rêvant de pouvoir
enfin réaliser ses projets dans
l'agriculture biologique il décide de
revenir en russie pour s'y installer
après des débuts difficiles la chance
tourne il finit par être présentés à un
homme d'affaires qui lui demande
fabriquer du camembert dans son
exploitation agro-industriel xavier
accepte le défi et met au point une
recette avec les moyens dont ils
disposent
cependant désirant mieux contrôler la
qualité de la production il décide de se
mettre à son propre compte les débuts
sont difficiles et ils commencent à
produire son fromage tout d'abord dans
sa maison puis dans la datcha d'un de
ses amis
dans la région de perm après de
nombreuses recherches il finit par
trouver une ferme écologique dans la
région d'ekaterinbourg où avec laquelle
il collabore maintenant
[Musique]
nous sommes partis dans un village près
d'ekaterinburg à l'est des monts de
l'oural est donc en asie cette fois nous
allons visiter la fromagerie de xavier
ici c'est la ferme denis coste et skoda
c'est des clientes j'ai eu puisque elle
choisit du conseil ils m'ont trouvé je
sais même pas comment d'ailleurs
ont demandé si je pouvais venir voir
aider à la ferme résulte des problèmes
avec le lait tout ça donc je suis venu
et puis après en revenant je me suis
donc occupé aussi donc principalement de
la fromagerie en plus des vaches que
c'est une ferme avec une fromagerie
comme faé sa ferme avec une fromagerie
dans des cochons des moutons des chèvres
ils ont combien de vache ils ont cinq
ans de vaches à la traite la donc du
coup je me suis dit tiens je pourrais en
attendant de monter mon projet
webcam fromagerie je pourrais faire des
fromages ici c'est immoral c'est pas
loin donc je fais les fromages ici je
les ai des mois les fromages peu que
j'ai fait je peux les vendre ouais de
faire du comité en fait ils devaient un
assortiment qui correspondait un peu à
ce que j'avais envie de faire et de
vendre et du camembert il ya vu qu'ils
avaient des jeunes et des fromages ouais
ouais ouais bon moment sur des fromages
appelé emmental gruyère et compagnie
mais qui sont pas les
et les vraies recettes quoi pourquoi les
fromages c'était déjà une passion
ben non pas une passion mais bon j'ai
fait mon bts agricole c'est vrai que
j'avais pas fait trop de chromage ça
c'est bizarre que j'ai pas bien je sais
pas tu sais pas à quel moment il les a
fait un truc parce que j'aurais pu aller
faire un stage en chèvre et j'étais en
stage en vache mais il n'y avait pas de
transformation sur la fermer et que des
vaches et moi c'était j'avais pas fais
le lien vraiment fait dans ma tête à
cette époque-là de si je l'avais fait un
peu dans un projet mais je m'étais pas
dit tiens il faudrait dans une sphère où
ils font du du fromage quoi et après ben
quand il ya eu les sanctions ici
et c'est là qu'on m'avait proposé donc
de de faire du fromage
donc c'était le seul et sans supporter
unités ce
qui moi y avait pas de fromage
pour moi donc
ça va je suis français quand même donc
j'arrive encore à trouver du vin
français mais
c'est déjà assez cher et puis en plus
c'est pas bon
autant le faire soi-même quoi c'est un
peu toujours ça moi j'ai tout autant
faire soi même et si tu peux être
autonome sur un truc tu le fais
alors ici on récupère le lait est ce que
tu peux m'expliquer quelque chose
j'entends de la musique pourquoi y ait
de la musique c'est typiquement en
russie non non et c'est la première fois
que j'arrive à l'imposer
c'est ce qu'on appelle de la bio musique
il n'était pas contre donc j'ai fait en
sorte qu'ils mettent la musique et la
première fois qu'on a mais quand
commencer à mettre les disques le lait a
monté et en fait il n'avait pas assez de
places dans les trucs à déborder tout
comme m
est-ce que tu as apporté d'autres
techniques comme ça que les russes ne
connaissait pas pour un meilleur
rendement ou pour une meilleure qualité
des petites les petits petits détails
alors ben moi ce que je fais quand
j'arrive dans une ferme maintenant c'est
que je vais vérifier l'eau
j'ai contrôlé la qualité de l'eau
et les courants parasites après
je me suis un coin c'est comme ça c'est
un réfractomètre ça me permet de mesurer
le taux de sucre dans les liquides j'ai
des appareils de mesures physiques on
utilise partout pour la qualité de l'eau
et je fais de la science je prends des
démordez et comme en dehors des
échantillons jeu les mesures après je
peux lire forte dans des tableaux en
général cet effet la première fois je
fais ça pour voir après je fais tu
sérieusement j'avais un tableau aux
retours toutes les mesures et on fait un
bilan soit
chez au niveau idiote il commence son
analyse avec le lait et il va jusqu'aux
produits d'entretien que nous utilisons
c'est un processus technologique complet
tout est lié et nous ne pouvons pas
faire de la production de fromage sont
des propriétés particulières du lait
on est plusieurs fromagers donc il ya un
fromager qui fait une recette c'est lui
qui fait tout de a à z ou windows ils
l'aident donc ici il ya quoi y'a du goût
il ya des gouttes des sortes de godard
et puis
des gruyères 4 shota il ya des fromages
italiens donc il ya des fromages
français voilà donc gruyère emmental
d'accord et moi donc je suis plus cela
il ya du camembert aussi du chèvre c'est
toi qui a porté les recettes
moi j'ai corrigé j'ai apporté mes
recettes en fait livré recettes comment
on fait chez nous parce qu'ils aient pas
comme il fallait
enfin une visite d'une autre façon donc
du coup voilà on a changé les recettes
est avec toi en tant que consultant
c'était arrivé parfois de leur dire
voilà il faut faire ça comme ça et ça
les a étonnés et une chose batailler
pour tout faire c'est je dois me faire
entendre il va moi je vous dis qu'il
faut on fait comme ça en europe
il faut essayer le gruyère ici à de
grier il ya le gruyère que je fais moi
est une guerrière qui font le
met à la finalité le résultat ils s'en
rendent compte que la manière dont tu
l'a préparé le fromage est peut-être
meilleur est différent alors ils n'ont
pas l'habitude du coup c'est ça les gens
ils n'ont pas l'habitude du bo un peu
plus fort un peu plus prononcée ceux qui
sont allés en europe ils ont déjà goûté
et si ça leur a plu au réalisateur mais
ceux qui sont ici ils ont pris
l'habitude du fromage un peu neutre
plastique pas trop de bons et camembert
il aime ce sera quand même là mais il
faut pas que ça sente alors raconté on
est à quelle étape
le lait était pasteurisé je ne pèse je
rajoute les ferments lactiques
donc on les laisse cinq minutes
apprendre l'humilité après on les a
mélangé très doucement et là on a laissé
le lait ça finit
[Musique]
allez je te laisse passer devant
lentement
le nail il a changé complètement de
structure il
est devenu semi solide comme du comme du
gel
[Musique]
c'est intéressant de travailler avec sa
vie' il est positif
xavier nous a fait découvrir le cas
ciotat nous n'avions jamais fait ça
avant le fromage hameury nous l'avons
goûter il nous a plu
en plus il nous a montré le camembert
1re hommage vraiment français nous avons
senti la différence
il a apporté une nouvelle technique
notre camembert est devenu meilleur le
morbier au site c'est entièrement sa
technique avant nous n'avions pas fait
de manguiers
alors où est ce qu'on aime ça sent bon
alors là on est dans l'eau chaude oui
asie montre un peu tous les fromages qui
doivent avoir des petits trous à
l'intérieur du fromage à trous ils
doivent passer dans une cale chose donc
ici il faut avoir au moins 16 degrés de
16 à 22 voilà ici ces trois fromages
différents donc il ya des gruyères le
gouvernator ski
et puis là il y en a des masses d'un
bientôt normalement là il faudrait les
gruyère moi avec ma méthode on laisse à
la sec et on les lave avec de la mort ce
qu'on appelle à morges c'est donc de
l'eau salée et à chaque fois qu'on lave
les fromages il va y avoir un petit peu
de fromage qui va tomber dedans et
normalement il ya du des moisissures une
bactérie brévine bacterial qui vont
pousser donc ça va ça va ça l'est ça va
donner du goût et le groove petit à
petit aller vers le centre en tout cas
ça sent très bon moi j'adore la
dégustation avec
on aura une petite dégustation bien sûr
parce que je suis gourmand
bas comme moi je fais du fromage quand
même
[Musique]
alors les mental donc ça c'est que j'ai
déjà testé c'est un des premiers que
j'ai fait
il à celui-là il a il avait six mois là
bas vous bochenko côtière
waouh
[Musique]
quelles ont été tes premières
impressions de la russie c'était un rêve
d'enfant devenir donc enfin
d'adolescents choisi russe première
langue donc c'est l envie de venir et
donc c'est s était enthousiaste et en
même temps c'était surprenant quoi
qu'est ce qui te manque le plus en
russie ce qui manque le plus c'est ouais
c'est un petit peu là
c'est beaucoup la cuisine est ce qui
manque après celle à l'ordre enfin à
l'ordre un espèce de une espèce de
logique de d'efficacité dans le travail
ça c'est vraiment un problème
est-ce quelque chose que tu n'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre ici
il y avait des pays amis des questions
pièges on avait dit je pense que c'est
pour tout le monde pareil c'est
sait comment ils font tous offerts avant
de réfléchir qu'est ce que la russie
représente pour toi
bah là maintenant ça représente le pays
où j'ai su finir mais souvent ça va être
ma masse ma seconde patrie voilà ce
qu'est ce que la réussite a amorcé
une forme de liberté ouais un grand
merci ce fut un plaisir de te rencontrer
et puis je te souhaite une bonne
continuation
eh bien ces gens qu'il est devenu et
puis ben moi aussi c'était vraiment un
plaisir faire partager
ce que je fais
ce qui m'anime
[Musique]
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous l'avons passée en compagnie de
xavier fort qui nous a fait goûter et
découvrir ses excellents fromages
fabriqués en russie de nouveaux lieux de
nouvelles personnalités toutes aussi
intéressantes nous attendent je vous dis
à très bientôt sur la défense
[Musique]